my four-year-old and I have just
literally been passing this thing back
and forth fun so I'm hoping to get home
and not have my seven-year-old have this
where is he
she's at home yeah they're with Grandma
we're in Los Angeles yes yeah that was
Charlize Theron on the view Tuesday
correcting the pronoun joy behar used
for her seven-year-old daughter Jackson
where is he
she's at home yeah they're with grandma
now in a new interview with pride source
the bombshell star admits she's always
learning when it comes to parenting
including what pronouns to use for her
child Jackson who was assigned male at
birth quote my daughter's story is
really her story and one day if she
chooses she'll tell her story I feel
like as her mother for me it was
important to let the world know that I
would appreciate it if they would use
the right pronouns for her charlise
added quote it became harder for us the
older she got that people were still
writing about her in the wrong pronouns
and also I was still talking about her
in the press using the wrong pronoun it
really hurt her feelings I don't want to
be that mom and that was really why I
said what I said a while back
charlisse seems to be referring to an
interview she did back in April with the
Daily Mail where she revealed that when
Jackson was three years old she told her
quote I am NOT a boy Charlize continued
telling pride source she hasn't talked
about it since adding it's really up to
her to decide if she wants to share that
et caught up with Charlize in September
to talk about her flick The Addams
Family
what a lovely morning and she opened up
about how her own family is not that
different I've always been intrigued and
encouraging of us kind of relooking at
what what we think that image of the
family should look like right and this
is such a classic long-term endearing
family that we've known since the 60s
and really what they've always stood for
is that yes we're weird we're different
and we don't look like everything else
or everybody else out there and that's
what makes us that's what we bring to
the table and I I just think it's so
timely to tell that story and to be able
to be part of something like that with
two small children is it's a it's really
nice
[Music]